a mí me interesa mucho las experiencias
de trabajadores latinoamericanos a un
latin ex en el sector sin fines de lucro
especialmente mujeres y personas de
género no binario por varias razones
primero m en mis experiencias trabajando
en la piedra latinoamericana por los
últimos 10 años yo vi que mujeres y
personas del género no binario estaban
haciendo mucho trabajo muchos logros la
justicia social pero que no fueron
reconocidos ni dentro de la comunidad
latinoamericana y tampoco en la más
amplia sociedad canadiense entonces para
mí esto fue un gran problema que yo
quería explorar y aportar porque sí como
una comunidad queremos progresar en una
manera ética en una manera
que lucha por la justicia social
entonces tenemos que empezar con las
personas más marginadas por la presión
estructural
como personas latinas volatín ex
indígenas mujeres las alicia las
realizadas a jóvenes y personas de bajos
recursos personas cuyas personas trans y
eso es lo que tratan de hacer a los
trabajadores a la tri next
aquí yo interese para mi proyecto